all right let's talk about AOC
Alexandria okay zoo Cortez I just
complained last week about people
talking about her too much conservatives
talking about her too much and then Here
I am a few days later like a hypocrite
but I you know I feel like it's not that
hypocritical because I don't want to
talk about her exactly there's just one
thing that she said one thing that's
gotten a lot of attention like
everything else she says gets a lot of
attention it's also attracted a lot of
criticism rightfully so but I think
we're kind of missing an important point
because there's something legitimately
interesting and kind of instructive
about what she said but we're missing it
we're missing it so this was on 60
minutes not long after she proposed that
70 percent tax which would result in
massive unemployment and destroy the
economy but she said something you know
on this during the interview she said I
think that there's a lot of people more
concerned about being precisely
factually and semantically correct then
about being morally right okay so she's
she's complaining that people are more
concerned about being factually right
than about being morally right obviously
as many people have pointed out the
number one problem here is that this is
what we call a false dichotomy it's a
false choice she's making us choose
between two things when actually we can
have them both you can be factually
correct and morally correct most of the
time the two things aren't even
necessarily you know they aren't
necessarily related so if I were to say
that a triangle has three sides
I am factually correct am i morally
correct well it's that it's a morally
neutral thing to say it's not it's not I
don't think anyone would say that
triangles are morally correct they're
just that's what they are it's just a it
is a it's a matter of fact but whenever
you you do or say so if you say
something if you make a point that is
morally correct then you are also going
to be factually correct
so I can say that it's that abortion is
morally wrong
because you're killing a human being
which is morally wrong I am both morally
correct and factually correct it
wouldn't be possible now so it is
possible for me to say things that are
factually correct like a triangle has
three sides and yet morally neutral but
it's not possible for me to say
something that's factually correct and
morally wrong because if it's factually
correct then it's true and if it's true
then either it's just morally neutral
just is or it's morally right so this is
not this isn't something we have to
choose if so we have to decide when
someone says something like this if we
wanted to be generous to them if we
wanted to find a way to for it to make
sense right then then maybe we would say
well the point that she's trying to make
is that people get too caught up on the
semantics of things and you know they're
looking at them at the minutiae and
everything when really let's look at the
moral core of what we're talking about
and not get hung up on all the little
specifics and details if we wanted to be
generous to order we would say that
that's what she meant but I don't know
if there's any reason to be generous or
to her in this case especially because
based on other things she said and based
on what the left says in general the
other way of interpreting it is that
she's saying
well sometimes morality can trump truth
you know sometimes you do have to choose
between being between the truth between
what's factually correct and what's
morally right and in those cases then
you have to choose what's morally right
the problem though is that when she says
morals what she really means is feelings
so what she really means is sometimes
you have to choose between what's
actually true and what feels good or
what feels right and so that's what she
means and that's completely wrong but
that's not really the point okay that's
that's not the point that I want to make
here the bigger point I think
you have this whatever twenty
nine-year-old congresswoman the big star
of the Democrat Party and she's on 60
minutes and what is she doing okay how
is she she's trying to justify her
various terrible positions and opinions
and how does she do it she does it on
moral grounds she is making a moral
argument now it's a faulty moral
argument
it's a ridiculous moral argument and her
idea of morality is completely wrong as
I said what she when she says morally
right what she means is feels right
feels good so it's morally right to tax
rich people up to seventy percent it's
morally right in the fact that it just
it makes people feel good it's like it
feels like they're too rich let's take
their money that's what she means by
morals but now that that that's the case
but the fact remains she is still trying
to make a moral argument and I've been
met this is a point that I've been
making for years now the left has this
is what the left does the left makes
moral arguments yes they make them
wrongly they have the wrong idea about
what morality is they make the arguments
dishonestly yes that's all true but they
still they still latch on to that
concept of morality and that's how they
package their arguments Bernie Sanders
did the same thing Nancy Pelosi is
running around this week saying that
well we can't have it we can't have a
wall down on the southern border because
it's immoral walls are immoral it's
immoral to have walls of course except
for the walls that she has on her house
right those those walls are perfectly
fine and most of the other walls that
she comes across in her daily life that
are meant to keep people out she's fine
with them but just having a wall on the
southern and and for other countries to
have walls on their borders
that's fine she would never judge them
right you can't judge other cultures but
it's our our wall is immoral she says
again it's a stupid moral argument it's
a wrong moral argument but it is still a
moral argument the significant point is
that what the left does even though
their moral relativists
and even though most of the time they
sound like hedonist and even though
they'll stand up and justify things like
killing babies in the womb they still
make the moral argument and why do they
do that they do that because that's what
speaks to people okay that's what gets
people motivated that's what sends
people into the streets marching you're
not gonna find anyone at a March or a
rally with like a practical slogan on
their banner or the poster that they're
carrying around while they're chanting
their mottos no the slogans the things
that you put on the on the banners and
the signs and the mottos that you march
under are always moral it's always this
is right that's wrong you know we're
standing for what's right we're standing
against what's wrong Nancy Pelosi knows
that on a practical level there's no way
that you can't on a practical and
economic level there's no way to argue
against protecting the border it
obviously makes good practical sense and
it obviously makes economic sense what
she's saying and what the left always
says about everything is yeah you know
what even if it is practical even if it
is economically the the right thing to
do it's just wrong it's morally wrong
and so that's why we shouldn't do it so
while the left has been making the moral
argument for these many decades the
right increasingly has has a fled from
from those kinds of arguments people on
the right you know what you find the the
common kind of Republican idea is that
if you want to speak to people if you
want to win people's hearts then you get
to them through their wallet or you get
to them through their practical concerns
but we don't want to talk about morality
we don't want to get into that because
then we're gonna be accused of being
theocratic and trying to legislate
morality and so on we don't want to be
accused of that so we're gonna make the
practical are we're gonna make the
economic argument because that's what
people care about wrong actually that's
wrong of course people do care about
money they do care about practicality
but the thing that speaks to people's
most first and foremost is our
principles morality people want to feel
like they're just they're living the
right way they have the right views on
things they're standing for the right
principles and if people are going to
mobilize and take to the streets and
make sacrifices for something they're
gonna do it for something moral because
they think they have the right there on
the right moral side and the problem is
that on the right we have basically
ceded that ground to the left it's
almost as if we've said well you know
what if you care about morality go go
over there what we're not talking about
that which is exactly the wrong way of
going about it
what we need to be communicating whether
it's with the wall or with taxes or gun
rights or any of the so-called social
issues abortion what on any of these
issues I think the first thing we need
to be pointing out is that this is
morally right this is the right moral
thing to do to protect the border is the
right moral thing it's morally right to
give people economic freedom it's more
yes it also is gonna lead to job growth
and all that great stuff more money in
your pocket more money in a while but
before any of that it's morally right a
man has the moral right to his own you
know to the fruits of his own labor to
put food into the mouths of his children
without it being stolen by the
government and given to someone else
that's the moral that should be the
first argument we make because that's
what speaks to people and that's why the
left has been winning for decades is
because there's
the people on that level if you want
your cause to win hearts and win minds
it has to it has to make it has to it
has to position itself as the right
moral cause and and more than that it
has to make moral demands it has to it
has to ask for sacrifice you know that's
on the Left that's part of the
attraction of that's why they're always
arguing for higher taxes because it now
it's true that the people who are
demanding higher taxes won't be the ones
paying the higher taxes so it's easy for
them to say right but even so part of
the attraction for the left when it
comes to higher taxes and when it comes
to their economic philosophy in general
is that it feels like a sacrifice even
though they're not making any sacrifice
but it feels like one and people want to
feel like they're sacrificing for a
cause and the leaders of the left
understand that and so that's why they
unabashedly are going to say yeah let's
pay higher taxes you know what we all
need to make sacrifices again yes when
they say we they don't really mean we
they mean they but they say we because
that people want to feel like that
that's one of the secrets of
progressivism just like it was one of
the secrets of communism actually yeah I
read this book recently it's called it's
a it's an obscure book dedication and
leadership which I don't know if you
could find it anywhere by a guy named
Douglas Hyde and the interesting name of
the book this this guy was it was
written I don't know a few decades ago
and this guy was a in a an avowed
communist back in this the 70s he was a
big-time radical communist and then he
got out of communism
and came to the light but then he wrote
this book talking about you know what
communists did right how they were able
to attract so many people especially
young people and this is one of the the
points that he makes is that communist
the reason why that movement appealed to
young people so much is that the
Communists made demands they made moral
arguments bad moral arguments but they
made moral arguments and they made
demands of their adherence and they
asked for sacrifice and that's what
people want that's how you motivate
people and this is something that I just
think the church needs to realize this
and and and the right needs to realize
that conservatives need to realize this
we need to stop we need to stop letting
the left left us be the only ones who
talk about morality that's the point
okay the the APA monitor which is the
flagship magazine of the American
Psychological Association had had this
headline on Twitter yesterday
it says APA has issued its first ever
guidelines for practice with men and
boys they draw in more than 40 years of
research showing that traditional
masculinity is psychologically harmful
and that socializing boys to suppress
their emotions causes damage traditional
masculinity is psychologically harmful
they say so let's take a look at this
from APA org the article about the
guidelines at APA org says in part prior
to the second wave feminist movement in
the 1960s all psychology was the
psychology of men most major studies
were done only on white men and boys who
stood in as proxies for humans as a
whole researchers assumed that
masculinity and femininity were opposite
ends of a spectrum and healthy
psychology entailed identifying strongly
with the gender roles confirmed
conferred by a person's biological sex
well yeah I mean that's that space
right actually but just as this old
psychology left out women and people of
color and conformed to gender role
stereotypes that also failed to take
men's gendered experiences into account
once
psychologists began studying the
experiences of women through a gender
lens it became increasingly clear that
the study of men needed the same gender
aware approach the main thrust of the
subsequent research is that traditional
masculinity marked by stoicism
competitiveness dominance and aggression
is on the whole harmful men socialized
in this way are less likely to engage in
healthy behaviors and researchers at
Boston College found that the more men
conformed to masculine norms the more
likely they were to consider as normal
risky behaviors such as heavy drinking
using tobacco and avoiding vegetables
and they were more likely to engage in
these risky behaviors themselves
avoiding vegetables is now considered a
risky behavior I had no idea I was such
a rebel I mean I'm kind of I I'm excited
actually I I I was thinking recently how
I I don't really engage in any risky
behaviors anymore I feel sort of old and
lame but I didn't realize that every
time I forgo my vegetables in favor of
another helping of just pure meat that I
was doing something risky and rebellious
so that's kind of exciting
all right stoicism Competitiveness
aggression are harmful traits now the
problem of course is that these have
been male traits since time immemorial
since the beginning of time and you are
calling something harmful which has
always been a part of the male identity
now psychologists and psychiatrists they
try to flip this around and it's kind of
a chicken or egg thing so what they'll
say is that well no you see society
decided that men were supposed to be
stoic and competitive and aggressive and
so then little boys grow up and they see
what society is saying and they try to
conform themselves to those expectations
but actually you see that
and that this is what you get from
psychologists and psychiatrists and the
you know so-called mental health experts
you get these they make these
proclamations that are that are
ideological philosophical theoretical
what they aren't is scientific
it seems very rare these days that you
hear anything actually scientific from
these people these are they just they
make these they just declare these
things about how people work how men
work how women work how people are
supposed to be how society is supposed
to be and we all just listen to them
unquestioning because they have a they
have an MD or whatever well actually
psychologists don't even have MDS or
psychiatrists don't have them these buts
I forget which one it is but it doesn't
matter this that is that's not a
scientific you know conclusion because
the fact is it goes the other way around
men are just naturally more competitive
competitive more aggressive less
emotional that's how men have always
been it's biological it's ingrained and
society noticed that about men so it's
not that society as this kind of
abstract entity hovering above us
decided that men are supposed to be that
way
no society which is just you know we are
also society or just a group of people
it's just the people we all live
together in a civilization we're a
society and so we have noticed this
about men and about ourselves and so
that's where these gender norms came
from they're not arbitrary is the point
this is just how men are so when you say
that it's harmful what you're saying is
that the male identity itself is harmful
and then you wonder why they complain in
this article about how men are less
likely to go and seek help from mental
health experts well do you think maybe
this is why because you're sitting there
say
that there's something wrong with all
men that you know there's something
diseased and disordered about manhood
and then you expect men to go to you and
listen to you as you try to turn them
into women now I'm not saying that all
psychologists and all psychiatrists do
that that's not my point but when you
have when you have this kind of thing
coming from the American psycho psycho
logical Association it's going to have
the effect of turning men off of
psychology and psychiatry and that's
there if it's not the men's it's not
it's not the fault of men it's the fault
of them of these so-called mental health
experts who have long ago ventured way
outside of the of the parameters of
actual mental health and they have
gotten into philosophy and and you know
social engineering and all that kind of
stuff this is the the and by the way
what's what's wrong with with being
stoic or being competitive what exactly
is wrong about it you know of course
all personal traits have to be balanced
so it's possible whatever your
personality is whatever personal
character trait we're talking about it's
possible to be too much that thing and
there are going to be situations and
circumstances for you that call for you
to be less one way and more another way
so obviously there's got to be a balance
but generally speaking men are going to
be less emotional more competitive more
aggressive there's nothing wrong that's
just that's just how people we are
there's nothing wrong with it again that
is a subjective determination that the
American Psychological Association has
made and there's no reason why we should
listen to it who are they who made them
experts on people that's the problem
they they do not confine themselves to
talking you know only about the brain
and what's going on in the brain and
what's going on neurologically with
people instead they have the the you
know psychiatrists and psychologists
what they've done is they have declared
you know this is how a human being is
supposed to be and if you're not that
way then you need drugs that's what
they've done but they have no authority
to do that they are not experts on the
entire human person this is the disease
of fiying of masculinity and it
continues unabated it starts at a very
young age with boys in school I've
talked about this many times there's a
reason why ADHD seems to mysteriously
affect boys much more often than it
affects girls and nobody ever asks that
question again so many people they just
go along with it because they're told
they have they've got psychologists
going around saying well if the ADHD and
so everybody just listens and says okay
well they said it so it must be true
nobody ever stops and thinks how honest
I go
is it that this if this is some
neurological condition why is it so much
more common in boys and why you know why
does it seem to only really be a problem
in the public school setting you know
why do we have so much ADHD coming out
of the public schools and not very much
of it coming out of home schooling why
is that nobody ever stops and ask these
questions it's because we have taken we
have taken boyhood and we have disease
if I'd it and medicalized it and we have
slapped this medical label on it and
called an ADHD so it starts at a young
age and then it goes all the way into
manhood and an adulthood and it just
never ends and we are destroying entire
generations of men by telling them that
there's something wrong with the fact
that they are men and that they should
be fundamentally different from how they
naturally are and that just it ruins
people it destroys people all right I
want to make brief mention of this the
BBC BBC three actually tweeted an
article a few days ago with an
interesting title the title was we need
to talk about thin privilege the article
apparently is from a few months ago but
it's it's making the rounds now for
whatever reason we see if I can find the
article the title the article is what is
thin privilege and who has it well I'm
guessing thin people have it my guess is
thin people have it but well we'll find
out
it says buying clothes and high street
shops and sitting comfortably a train
and plane seeds are things some people
take for granted but not for much longer
as lingerie blogger Cora Harrington says
these things mean you probably benefit
from thin privileged lingerie bloggers
that what does that mean that you're
blogging in your lingerie or what what
is I don't know what that means or you
blog about lingerie every day well how
much is how much is there to say about
lingerie that that could actually be
your job but well we'll put that to the
side in a detailed Twitter thread Cora
says you don't have to feel thin to have
thin privilege it just means you're not
on the receiving end of other people's
fat phobia yeah
fat phobia is a thing no and you don't
find it difficult to do everyday things
because of your size and then she goes
on and they're quoting from her tweet
thread explaining what explaining what
thin privileges she says my job involves
looking at photos of models who are much
thinner than me so I rarely feel thin
but I can also walk into almost any
clothing store and expect without even
thinking about it to buy something in my
size that is thin privilege and then she
goes on to explain and describe other
examples of thin privilege just just
just one point I'm not gonna spend a lot
of time on this but it's just first of
all
this idea of privilege has been just
stretched into oblivion
I mean 20 years ago if you had if you
said oh that person over there is
privileged everybody would know what
you're talking about they would get a
general idea they would think of like a
rich guy on a yacht or they would think
of a you know a rich kid in a fancy
private school okay that's privileged
someone who's has a lot of money hasn't
faced a lot of challenges in life silver
spoon and all that that's a privileged
person and so we all okay so that's what
it meant but now we have we have kind of
dissected people into a million pieces
and analyzed every part of their life
and said okay that part's privileged
you've got privileged over there you've
got privileged they're privileged
they're privileged and it doesn't mean
it's it so now everybody's privileged in
one way or another so they say that you
know you have you have white privilege
but then if you're fat then you don't
have privilege so then what about a fat
white person versus a skinny black
person so you know who has more
privilege there we get into a privilege
we get into the privileged oppression
Olympics right and we have a competition
about who's more privileged to us less
probably it's just it's so ridiculous
it's not the word doesn't mean anything
anymore and even if it does mean
something you know what stop whining
just stop whining about oh they have
more privileged than I have okay we'll
just shut up and just live your life
okay yes everybody is going to be
privileged in certain ways that you
aren't and then you're gonna have
certain privileges that other people
don't have I mean that's just that's
what it means to live and to be a human
being there are certain advantages that
you have that other people down there
are advantages that they have that you
don't and if you chose if you choose to
focus on the advantages that other
people have and you don't have that's
your that's your fault that's your
problem
and if you choose to see you to see
society like this and to see life this
way as this constant like jockeying for
position about who's gonna be more
victimized if that's how you want to
live that's your choice but that's not
much of a life the other option is just
to shut up about it and just live it's
uh and also obesity is is not it's not
an identity okay it's not it's not a
community so we can't talk about well oh
the the obese community and and the
struggles that they face yes people that
are overweight they do face certain
struggles I'm not I'm not downplaying
that but there's not a that's not a like
a category of person if you're obese it
just means you have a little bit extra
weight on you and probably if you go on
a diet and you get some exercise you'll
get rid of some of that weight so it's
not that doesn't make you I might as
well talk about the you know I'm six
foot one I might as well talk about the
six foot one community and here are the
struggles and challenges that we face
it's not a it's not a it's just it's
just how tall I am and that actually I
can't do anything about but if you've
got extra weight on you you certainly
can do something about it now now it may
be true that you're never going to be
the rail-thin
but that's fine but everybody in the
world you know if you whatever whatever
your weight is now you can change it at
least to some degree just by changing
your lifestyle and your diet and
everything else let's just let's just
stop focus my proposal okay for
everybody I mean whatever whatever you
are fat skinny whatever race whatever
culture however much money you have stop
focusing on privilege and and and what
other people have and you don't have
stop whining about it and just go and
live okay that's my that's my pep talk
for the day all right
finally a couple of two other things
two little pieces of video I want to
show you here we go first to an incident
at the Fort Lauderdale airports a woman
was apparently denied entry into onto a
flight because she was intoxicated and
then well here she is interacting shall
we say with the gate agent
okay I just I just want to say one thing
here okay i i'm not gonna criticize this
woman actually I totally understand
where she's coming from I mean I feel
exactly the same way every time I'm in
an airport I have exactly the same
villain who among us has not been
sitting at the gate screaming silently
to yourself you know get me out of here
no I don't want to do this that's I
think that every single time I'm in an
airport in fact I scream in agony to
myself at airports at the DMV the
grocery store the mall I scream to
myself in agony anytime somebody calls
me on the phone rather than text me and
I get sucked into an actual conversation
the whole time I'm thinking this the
exact same thing the woman's saying and
it's even worse at airports because
you're sitting in this horrid
environment waiting to be in an even
more hard environment and that's what
makes waiting like at the dentist so
terrible also because it's not like
you're waiting in line for a ride at
Disney World you're waiting and and and
it's not fun but then what you're
waiting for will be even less fun so
you're waiting in line at the airport
for the privilege of being you know
packed into a tin box like chickens on
one of those poultry trucks you see on
the highway and then you're gonna be
suspended 30,000 feet in the air where
what one wrong move one gust of wind one
cellphone not put on airplane mode could
send you plummeting to the earth and a
death spiral so yeah I get where she's
coming from the only difference the only
thing that really separates the same
from the insane is that insane people
scream out loud whereas sane people keep
it to themselves being able to scream
silently in agony in your head that's
that's that's what that's what makes you
sane and normal and we all do it so let
us not judge this woman for expressing
and for and for exercising her free
speech rights as well even though she
did say that she had a gun at airport
which you know I guess is ill-advised
okay last thing the college football
playoff national championships happened
yesterday
Clemson won handily but something
something very strange occurred during
the halftime show the band imagine
dragons gave a perfectly subpar
performance and then the rapper Lil
Wayne came out in his Technicolor
Dreamcoat and here's how that went
so it appears that Lil Wayne's stylist
is from middle-earth or something he
looks like what would happen if somebody
slipped LSD into my grandmother's tea
okay it looks like his fashion designer
is like a an elf who made his outfit by
you know killing a unicorn
you know yeah he looks kind of like the
the love child of Elton John and a
muppet
or he looks a little bit like like the
mascot on a box of cereal actually he
looks like what would happen if Tim
Burton had a fashion show you know what
no no this I think this is it he looks
he looks kind of like a four-year-old
girl raided her mom's closet and tried
to dress up like a grown-up but it just
so happens that her mom is Cruella De
Vil from the 101 Dalmatians but you know
what he pulls it off I mean he doesn't
pull off the music so much which is
terrible if you can even call it music
but the outfit I mean he pulls it off we
got to give him credit so I get it I get
what he was doing with the whole
ensemble and I kind of liked it
alright we'll leave it there thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
Godspeed